ahora vamos a hacer una configuración
diferente para el amplificador
operacional está dibujada parcialmente
aquí y hablaré de esto mientras dibujo
el resto del circuito esto se compone de
una configuración resistiva que se ve
así tiene resistencias en la parte
superior
y éste será el voltaje de salida como lo
hicimos antes ahora tenemos una conexión
de esta manera y esta terminal está
conectada a tierra
esta es la terminal inversora y esta
terminal es la no impresora y esto es lo
contrario a lo que hemos hecho hasta
ahora y ahora por la atención particular
en esta que tiene el signo negativo
arriba tenemos a
r1 y r2
este es el voltaje de entrada
y particularmente lo que queremos hacer
es encontrar una expresión para el
voltaje de salida
en función
el voltaje de entrada
y en este vídeo lo haré de la manera
difícil
y lo que significa de la manera difícil
es que haremos todo el desarrollo
algebraico para obtener la expresión y
en el siguiente vídeo te enseñaré la
manera sencilla la manera sencilla es
muy divertida de aprender pero ayuda
mucho ver la manera difícil una vez para
apreciar la manera fácil
otra cosa que haremos en este vídeo es
que haremos el desarrollo algebraico
aprovecharemos esta ganancia para hacer
algunas suposiciones asi que continuemos
desarrollamos una expresión para el
voltaje de salida en términos del
voltaje de entrada primero escribamos
algunas cosas que sabemos del voltaje de
salida de acuerdo
sabemos que el voltaje de salida es
igual a a por por los regulares b más
menos b menos éste esté más y éste esté
menos por lo regular esta expresión de
aquí es de más menos b menos y ya que
demás es 0 escribiremos menos b menos
y esto equivale a decir que de menos es
igual
a menos el voltaje de salida
/ a
qué más podemos describir para este
circuito
veamos estas resistencias que tenemos
llamemos a este más menos de r1 y
llamemos a este más menos
r2 tenemos una corriente fluyendo aquí a
la cual llamaremos i
sólo utilizaré la ley de ohm y la r1
aquí para describir una expresión para
ahí
es igual a de r1 sobre r
otra manera en la que puedo escribir
esto es cual voltajes este este es ve -
puedo escribir esto en términos de ve -
y eso es igual
el voltaje de entrada - p - sobre r
1 esa es la corriente que pasa a través
de esta resistencia y utilizaré algo
especial que 7 este amplificador lo que
sea del amplificador operacional es que
esta corriente de aquí es igual a 0 no
hay corriente que fluye en un
amplificador operacional en la realidad
y puedo tomar ventaja de eso lo que
quiero decir es que sólo fluye a través
de r 2 por lo tanto deja de escribir una
expresión para y basándome en lo que
encontré aquí basándome en r2 y puedo
escribir i
es igual a hagámoslo
r2 sobre rezos
y puedo escribir de r2 como de menos
menos el voltaje de salida
sobre r2 bien tome ventaja de que no
fluye corriente hacia abajo para
escribir una expresión indicando que
toda la corriente cruza ahora igual
haremos estas dos déjame hacerlo aquí
abajo el voltaje de entrada
- ve - sobre r
esto es igual a este término de aquí que
es igual a b - menos el voltaje de
salida sobre r 2
lo que tenemos aquí es cuántas variables
tenemos aquí tenemos el voltaje de
salida el voltaje de entrada y ve - y
las que nos interesan solo son el
voltaje de salida y el voltaje de
entrada así que intentaré eliminar ve -
y lo haré con esta expresión de aquí
tomaremos ventaja de esta ecuación de
aquí para reemplazarme menos con menos
el voltaje de salida sobre a haré eso
aquí volveré a escribir eso es el
voltaje de entrada menos menos el
voltaje de salida sobre a esto se
convierte en positivo y esto es el
voltaje de salida sobre a
todo dividido entre r 1 y esto es igual
a menos que
- el voltaje de salida
sobre a
- el voltaje de salida entre r 2
bien ahora bajemos un poco para hacer
espacio
y continuamos que haré ahora ahora
multiplicaré ambos lados ahora para
quitarla de ahí abajo y me queda
por el voltaje de entrada más el voltaje
de salida
sobre r 1
es igual a menos el voltaje de salida
- ah
por el voltaje de salida sobre r 2
hay mucho desarrollo algebraico aquí
pero créeme se simplificará acá abajo en
un minuto
ahora dividiré esto en diferentes
términos para poder manejarlos de manera
separada
por el voltaje de entrada sobre r 1 más
el voltaje de salida sobre r 1 es igual
a menos el voltaje de salida sobre r 2
menos a por el voltaje de salida entre r
2 cambiemos los colores para que no nos
aburramos lo siguiente que haré es
intentar juntar todos los términos del
voltaje de salida en un lado y los
términos del voltaje de entrada en el
otro lado eso significa que este término
el voltaje de salida se irá al otro lado
tenemos a a
por el voltaje de entrada sobre r 1 eso
es igual a menos el voltaje de salida
sobre r2
- a por el voltaje de salida sobre r 2
este término pasa como menos el voltaje
de salida sobre r
bien no hemos cometido errores de signo
aún y ahora multiplicaremos ambos lados
por r 1
por el voltaje de entrada es igual a 1
sobre r2 menos el voltaje de salida
- r1
sobre r 2 x
por el voltaje de salida - el voltaje de
salida
la variable r 1 se canceló en este
último término
bien
en este es igual
y aquí puedo factorizar este término de
aquí - r 1 sobre r 2 por el voltaje de
salida
puedo factorizar lo de éste
puedo tener menos r 1 sobre r 2 por el
voltaje de salida por 1 más a menos el
voltaje de salida
analicemos esta expresión y usemos
nuestro criterio para decidir qué hacer
después ahora ya que es tan grande eso
significa que este primer término será
gigante comparado con este término del
voltaje de salida aquí el voltaje de
salida es un valor cercano a 5 volts o
menos 5 volts o un valor parecido y a
por esto es un valor cercano a 100.000 o
200.000 un valor cercano va a opacar a
este voltaje de salida así que lo
ignoraré por ahora solo lo cancelará de
esta manera y continuaremos sin ese
voltaje de salida en la expresión
después de haber aclarado eso ahora
tenemos al voltaje de entrada de este
lado y pasaré a al otro lado
no más a sobre a y este es un punto
donde debemos de utilizar nuestro
criterio otra vez nuevamente a es un
número muy grande como un millón por lo
que a más uno es un millón uno y esa
fracción es muy muy cercana a 1 así que
la ignorar sólo diré que es 1
consideraremos esto como
y déjame subir esto un poco más solo
para que tengamos más espacio ahora
tenemos que el voltaje de entrada es
igual a menos r 1 sobre r 2 por el
voltaje de salida
y quiero la expresión sólo en términos
del voltaje de salida así que lo
cambiaré de lado y tenemos que el
voltaje de salida es igual a menos r 2
sobre r 1 por el voltaje de entrada
así que esto es lo que nuestro
amplificador operacional está haciendo
por nosotros principalmente dice que el
voltaje de salida es la proporción de
dos resistencias por el voltaje de
entrada la ganancia del circuito
completo está determinada por la
proporción de esas dos resistencias y es
muy importante el signo negativo frente
a él el sexto - se mantuvo a través de
todo el desarrollo déjame volver a
dibujar el circuito rápidamente el signo
negativo arriba
es el voltaje de salida
aquí están r1 y
la entrada positiva la entrada no
inversora está conectada a la tierra
este patrón de la resistencia yendo por
arriba al menos este es llamado
click
cada dolor
inversor
y este es un patrón muy frecuente en los
circuitos con amplificadores
operacionales puedes ver esto en
diagramas y estarás diseñando los por ti
mismo tomó un largo desarrollo
algebraico al llegar a este punto y en
el siguiente vídeo te mostraré una
manera muy sencilla para hacer un
cortocircuito de todo esto y poder hacer
este análisis muy rápido a eso se le
llama tierra virtual